so
the jobs are drying up
the family is driving up the opportunity
to have a solid mate is drying up but we
there's a different men and women who
are in this similar situation who maybe
lose their job the 25 of women that were
in manufacturing losing their same job
they are responding different to this
economic situation women are more
adaptable than men to that kind of
change in circumstance they're more
likely to go back to school as one
example if you look at men who are
unemployed their propensity to go to
church or volunteer at a non-profit
actually goes down not up
when they're unemployed even though they
have more time
so one of the issues for
for guys is that without a livelihood
their sense of self-worth plummets and
then their
uh desire to go out and volunteer also
plummets do you know why that is i mean
i think that's like the core of this um
and we've been trying to get to better
equality of opportunity for men and
women but men and women are so different
and the numbers are screaming off the
page
i have thoughts too but it goes back to
kind of where we talk about video games
two men are more likely to dive into
video games or spend a lot of their new
free time spent on the computer in this
situation why do you think that is so
here's a quote from george orwell
a man with no means of filling up time
is as miserable out of work as a dog on
the chain
saying that if a guy there's another
saying you know idle hands are the
devil's tool devil's tools i think
they're referring to men
[Laughter]
primarily so women deal with idleness
better than men yes um women in a way
are not ever truly idle uh you know like
that they'll be able to improve their
environment uh improve themselves go
back to school
spend time with each other
that they don't have the same kind of
negative social externality
pattern that men do men who are idle
start gambling drinking uh doing drugs
and
uh become anti-social pretty quickly
right
and
a lot of people listening to those have
seen some version of this in their own
lives maybe they felt that and it's
something that i will say i personally
uh sympathize with a great deal one of
the things i i
i say in the war on normal people is
that every guy has the seeds of a failed
man inside of him right and so you can
see when someone does fail when a guy
fails you're like oh my gosh like that
could be me because you kind of know
yourself you know that there's some part
of you that just wants to go to the
basement and
hang out and
play video games and avoid the world
what are those seeds
in your eyes like what are the seeds of
a dysfunctional
man
you know what i'm saying like i think
every guy
well one of one of the one of the things
i joke about with evelyn sometimes
is that if you're an unmarried man
you your life will likely end earlier
like yeah you will die by the numbers by
the numbers you will die what is it
seven ten years earlier yeah it's almost
a decade right and if you are an
unmarried woman
no effect on your lifespan
like guys do not make women live longer
[Laughter]
we have no impact yes women uh make guys
live longer right and now that i am
married i understand why
um i also so i'm 47 i have friends who
are unmarried and may never marry and
you can see that the kind of returns on
male activities are going down
over time like i am so grateful to be
married in part because
the things that you get a charge out of
as a young man give you a little bit
less joy
as you as you get older and so you start
shifting gears where now i get pleasures
of you know like uh being a dad and like
bringing
the boys to a sporting event and living
vicariously through through them
and mellowing out and watching
uh you know succession with evelyn or
whatever it is
so you know you have like these
simple pleasures
um
and i think the seeds of failure for
guys are that
we need to feel some degree of
uh progress
achievement
stature appreciation virility
appreciation
and video games
uh form a perfect avenue for this
because
if you spend a bit of time you get
stronger you get more powerful you get
richer you get
more friends you get to win right this
comes you get a win uh and so here's a
quote
from jonathan gottschall who writes
about gaming virtual worlds give back
what has been scooped out of modern life
it gives us back community a feeling of
competence and a sense of being an
important person whom people depend on
yes yes and that is what a lot of what a
job does yeah and then what what's
fascinating to me and this is what i
kind of want to get into is that
the job or that sense of duty or
responsibility or appreciation or
respect that men are craving when it
when it's not there there's seeds of the
seeds of dysfunction seeds of
dysfunction
dysfunctional masculinity masculinity or
the dysfunctional male
start to seep in start to plant and
those are either i wrote down i was like
it's either thinking with the wrong head
which is the uh
sure the robin williams quotes like god
gave men two heads and only enough blood
to run one at a time it's probably i
think it's accurate i think avoiding
responsibility like almost hiding and
numbing the pain whether that's drugs or
alcohol or kind of that escapism
this is one thing that makes men subject
to
toxic ideologies in my opinion is that
there's this thirst for significance
and so if you don't
get that significance in your day-to-day
life and then someone has some idea
being like oh you know why things are
going badly for you because these people
are keeping you down and here's how we
can fight them then you start getting
attracted to that because it makes you
part of something important yes
and men crave that yes
there's a crave to take things like be a
man like that's yours or go get it um
and that can be done
well or very poorly in the way that men
approach women and things like that
there's the competition the ego the
hubris but also turns into apathy or
hate or racism you know these darker
pieces of
otherness or
other people are causing this
and so to me as a society we need to
talk about that and understand that
um frederick douglass what did he say
it's in your book he said uh
it's easier to build strong children
than to repair broken men
and when men start getting these seeds
it gets very very very difficult to
to come back and i've seen that in
there's a lot of industry work my dad
does you have men they're just
they're just broken they're beat this is
in some ways a grossly oversimplified
way to think about the struggle that
america is going through where you have
this
uh disintegrating way of life for
millions of men and a need for
significance
and anger
and and the the question is can we
manage
this process in a way that
keeps people strong and whole and
healthy and even understanding what's
happening right or is it going to be
like uh
you know oh like screw you like your
perspective is unimportant um you know
like we don't care about you uh and and
so one of the things i want to switch to
is what's happening among the college
educated cohort that ends up in in many
ways obscuring a lot of these struggles
correct yes so let's go there
so among the college educated crew it's
it's a very different environment so
let's say you have 58 women 42 men in
college
that might not seem that dramatically
different but it's it's a lot and over
time it gets so if the numbers if you
change the number slightly to 60 40. um
what that would mean is that
one-third of college-educated women
will not have a college-educated man to
marry
when they want to get married and
that is
the case um in part because
college-educated women will essentially
not consider any non-college-educated
man to get married in most circumstances
yeah by the numbers by the numbers right
so you'll wind up with a very
significant number of
college-educated women who will
not marry i mean they might decide to
have kids independently
and then they're going into environments
and it varies wildly by industry but the
the overwhelming narrative is that if
you look at certain environments
finance tech
media to you know
a large extent some of the most highly
visible
industries they tend to be somewhat male
dominated
and so
the movement is for women who are going
into this environment say hey we
outnumber men
at the
entry levels but then you go up to the
top let's say it's a law firm so i have
some experience with that environment
yeah the number of law school graduates
is essentially a gender gender parody
now male female
but if you look at the partnerships it's
like very very male dominated right um
and so
the active movement is to say hey this
stuff is out of whack we need more
female ceos you know more me female
partners we need more female board
members
and so the narrative is around
men marginalizing women in these
environments which is a very different
environment than what we were just
discussing which is like there are you
know legions of men who
don't have um meaningful opportunities
among the less educated set so in among
the educated universe it's like hey why
do guys have all the power and money
right
and
our response to that has been promoting
women faster i guess slowly but surely
like we are i mean have you seen
people or companies start to level the
playing field or you still think it's a
i it's still very very out of whack
is it improving marginally
my my perspective on this
is that a lot of these environments are
almost
intrinsically
um
women unfriendly and somewhat family
unfriendly yeah where and you worked on
wall street so you might be able to
speak to this so you worked in like a
slightly gentler sector world generally
so we have this uh winner take all
marketplace and if you look at finance
and tech and media
the winner take all dynamics are all
consuming where it's like look if we get
this deal or we get this market or
whatnot like we're all going to be rich
and then if we don't we are all going to
be poor
so yeah so everyone needs to go go go
and you come and be like look you need
to work uh you know
around the clock you need to be
available all the time and you do it for
years on end
and then you'll reap these massive
rewards
and so these cultures are
like completely subject to um these
market dynamics and so then if a woman
enters this organization it's like hey
like maybe i don't feel like working 70
or 80 hours a week um if you adopted the
same standard for everyone like women
would look up and be like you know let's
say i want to have a kid at some point i
actually want some some like you know
family time and the rest of it um then
they'll naturally self-select and be
like hey let me
leave this place at a certain point um
and then the organization will be back
to square one being like you know where
all the women in in senior management
leadership right so there are certain
cosmetic things they could do around it
being like maybe we should have more
generous policies than this but the
culture itself is going to be geared
towards the market that they're in right
oh no do i think that this is great no
do i think there should be a four day
work week which by the way would would
end up helping
help you know like help everyone because
like you know this is burning dudes out
too like this is like everyone's kind of
going crazy
um so that it's it's not purely a
gendered thing so i would love it if
organizations adopted more uh humane
cultures and
paces and you didn't have to answer
uh your phone and your email after a
certain hour and like the rest of like
all that stuff would make me very happy
right but i i will will suggest that if
even if you made these cultural shifts
um it's a very very different struggle
than the struggle that most
men or families are experiencing because
like the tendency is for media
employees to think of things in the same
way as happening in their company right
but you know what's happening in their
company is completely distinct from
what's happening in like you know some
working-class town and dessert
[Music]